major league debut called up from double
a san antonio
here is reece kinnear he has got to be
pumped right now the adrenaline through
his veins
san antonio double a numbers 11 starts
fastball he'll cut it throws a slider a
change up 92 to 95.
good start to his major league career
strikes out his first hitter
that's rhyme otopia down by way of the k
and that's line back up the middle so
the first time he went to a little bit
of a slider
dazzle was all over it and a one-out
single for dazza
who's been slumping he was two for his
last 25 before that
waiting on an o2 pitch from kinnear
bounce in and taking off for second base
dazzle the throw
high throw but the tag is there they got
him
oh interesting decision by jonathan
dazza
a very late move after that ball hit the
dirt
rivas threw down and chronoworth with
kind of the tatis-esque
tag got him as he went by 28 year old
left-hander from denver on the mound for
the rockies 1-2 this year with a five
and a half era
freeland as mentioned only his ninth
start of the season he began the year on
the il with the left shoulder strain
suffered that injury during spring
training and did not get his season
started until late may
3-1 pitch to tatis is hit towards right
going back blackman onto the track he'll
reach up and grab it
here comes jake cronin worth pitch
strike three called
kyle freeland strikes out cronenworth in
a one two three first
no score after one down in the count one
and two
kneers pitch is hit towards center field
going back christian it's over his head
bangs off the wall and deep right center
trevor's story with a lead off double to
begin the second inning
and the rockies have the bases loaded
nobody out with the catcher elias diaz
coming up
and he misses with it outside and that
forces in a run the base's loaded walk
makes it
one to nothing colorado there you go
swinging a miss and he strikes him out
second strikeout for kinnear tonight
needed that first out of the second
inning
bringing the heater two and two here's
the pitch and that one's kind of fisted
out towards shallow center cronenworth
is back
and he gets there to make the catch and
in the inning reece caneer just call him
harry houdini
rockies get one run on the bases loaded
walk to diaz but they leave them loaded
and we'll go to the bottom of the second
inning one to nothing colorado one away
manny's still at first base and eric
hosmer coming up and that's held by diaz
strike three on hosmer
second strikeout for freeland two gone
two-two and as curveball hit right at
cj crow and he'll go to the bag the two
walks do no damage
one to nothing rockies have the lead as
we venture into the last half of the
third inning
comes back with the one-two swing in a
miss
got rhys kaneer for out number one and
strikeout number three for freeland
popped him up
right side foul ground over near the
running track
cj krohn makes the catch and that'll do
it for the padres good inning for kyle
freeland
one two and three so freeland will bat
with a runner on first two down
one-nothing rockies in the fourth
hits one in the air deep left field fam
moving back he reaches up and the balls
off his glove
around third owings heading to the plate
and the throw
off line he slides in safely down to
second
kyle freeland and the rockies lead it
two to nothing
so it's a double an rbi it's a rocky's
two-nothing lead in the end of the night
for
kaneer in his major league debut hits it
on the ground first base way hosmer's
got it he'll flip to
diaz for the out that puts an end to the
top of the fourth
rockies get a run on a hit they leave a
man
drives one to right blackman going back
it's gonna be over his head and that's
gonna be off the bottom of the wall
chronoworth to second base starts things
in the bottom of the fourth with a wall
ball double
andres will bring the tying run to the
plate and one down in the bottom of the
fourth trent grisham coming up with uh
cronenberg still at second base
to center it's gonna drop for a base hit
here comes kronenworth
no throw padres are on the board they
cut the rockies lead in half
rbi single trent grisham it's a 2-1 game
in the fourth
and the pitch to the plate and it's hit
in the air
short right field blackman coming in
he's underneath it and puts it away
and freeland gets the job done against
myers
rivas over one grounded the first is
only other time up and he swings here
lines one right on into center field for
a base hit
second straight inning the padres get
the lead off man aboard against freeland
and miguel diaz will come up in a bunt
situation
diaz is going to bat for himself hits it
to second owings to story for one on to
first with a double play
on guess what the first pitch
how about that six pitches last inning
and two pitches and two outs here
they're going to get him again kyle
freeland induces a pop-up here's dazza
jonathan's got it it's been pop-out city
for much of the night for kyle freeland
he leads the padres after five
rockies two san diego one and he walked
in the second
hopped out to second base in the to left
field for machado
toffee on the runs not gonna get there
one hops up and over the wall
and that'll actually go against the
padres a little bit and hurt him because
it went over the wall
noteworth has to stop at third i think
he would have scored probably but
the rulebook double and it's second and
third with nobody out
rockies are clinging to a one-run lead
and freeland is going to depart
after gives up a single and a double to
start the bottom of the sixth inning
runners on second and third nobody out
for trent grisham he has driven in the
only padre run of the night so far an
rbi single and has lasted back
there's the pitch and trent swings hits
it on the ground right side long way to
go owings he gets there
spins from the outfield grass in the
throw to first in time
run comes in to score though jake
cronenworth crosses the plate and we are
2-2 in the sixth
two down mana machado at third base the
go ahead run for the padres
myers sends one towards the gap and left
center field
that is going to get down and roll
machado will score from third to second
with an rbi double goes will myers
and the padres take a 3-2 lead two on
two down for manny
loop to right that's gonna fall coming
around from second is fam
manny with a huge turn around first
didn't think anybody
was behind him and now he's caught
between first and second trying to slide
out of the way
with cronenworth racing home and the run
will not count
but either way one run scores and the
inning comes to a close
rbi single for machado but he ends up
hung up austin adams into the game for
san diego
39th game for the slider thrown
right-hander opponents leading 144.
yeah a few walks there strike three call
strikes out trevor story for the first
out of the eighth inning
that's straight three mcmahon knew it
takes with him the second strikeout for
austin adams
back-to-back case two down in the eighth
inning d-backs lead three to two in l.a
as this one is lined right to manny
machado makes the catch and the inning
is over another good
good inning of relief mark malanson the
closure for the padres
26 out of 30 in the same opportunity
category
a little tapper it'll be melanson his
throw is good ball game over
a one two three ninth inning for mark
malanson as the padres beat the rockies
four to two